dans notre prochaine nous avons Unis
toutes les classes de la société nous
avons essayé de résoudre pour une date
la plus proche possible la retraite
nationale pour tous les vieux de France
nous espérons fermement que le principal
sera adopté et que son démarrage sera
relativement rapide malgré l'important
et long travail de mise en application
alors la vraie la bonne retraite à 60
ans qu'est-ce que c'est c'est le droit
de partir et non pas l'obligation bien
sûr après 37 ans et demi de carrière et
ce qui est très important je crois que
les auditeurs doivent s'en rendre compte
c'est 37 ans et demi toute profession
auparavant nous on avait songé si vous
voulez on ne reliez pas les professions
entre elles tandis que là comme au fond
les gens changent de profession dans
leur vie toutes ces années comptent pour
leur ouvrir droit à la retraite à 60 ans
un système qui garantit la solidarité
entre les générations un système mis en
place au lendemain de la Libération
notamment par Ambroise Croizat ministre
communiste du travail du général de
Gaulle vous essayez de justifier votre
réforme en opposant une minorité de
travailleurs à la grande majorité
humidité de travailleurs qui auront
aussi deux ans de plus à travailler et
vous essayez de diviser la classe
ouvrière en citant Ambroise Croizat